[Музика]
якщо він має міжнародний в
останніх місяців у зв'язку з
збройний конфлікт в україні
справи з правами людини для всіх сторін
повинні визначити
до них належать викрадення та
особливо зловживання
і змусити його зникнути
ми сподіваємося, що зі зменшенням в
збройні конфлікти тут теж ні при чому
може обернутися на краще
однак це очікує, що тут
відповідальність за це
порушення прав людини
минулий також відповідник
нести відповідальність
національна меншина кримських татар
повторюється в останні місяці
різні обмеження
ваша думка про свободу
підлягали праву зібрань
сюди запрошуються всі учасники
Про це має подбати і Крим
міжнародні стандарти прав людини
поважати
був
просто
немає
[Музика]